What's uh, how are you guys doing? How are you boys doing?
Since last week we spoke about Claymore and I was like, it. I'll reclaim all.
And it was really good. You literally just finished it like.
Yeah, two minutes before we started recording.
If you haven't read clay morning, I think about it. Don't worry about it.
You don't even know anything. Uh, Mt.
Was good until the halfway and then it kinda just goes a bit. Yeah.
Yeah, definitely. Yeah. I feel like a lot of animation.
Do this where they build up like this amazing world that I think is too big of a
scope. And then they just let like, we need to finish this.
Like within like 200 chapters. How do we do that?
Yeah. Well I think for a lot of the times,
at least with like Sean and John cause claim was from Shawnee job.
A lot of the times the authors don't really have a choice as to how long he goes
for. Right.
Shannon jump goes through the same problem. As, you know,
a lot of American TV shows where, you know, you have some like rare,
like something like breaking bad, for example,
it's like a rarity where a show just gets better.
It hits its peak and then it stops, you know what I mean? But the problem with,
yeah, kind of like a spinoff, I think medical school's better than breaking bad
[inaudible] but uh, yeah, the problem with it, all of it like Shannon,
John manga,
is that the most of the time that you either go on for too short or they get
dragged out,
you either you're either like a bleach or you are something that gets canceled
early. Like most other shown and jump shows. That's the thing.
Right? Is that like with Sean and jump,
they have every month they have rankings and if you have even just a slight dip
in popularity, then they're kind of just like, well.
Time to wrap it up boy. And he also was like, well, I just, I just got started.
It's it doesn't matter. I got to wrap it up. I'm wondering.
That's what happened. But to be fair,
when I was reading this it's 150 chapters around, like the 80th is, I was like,
ah, yeah, this isn't going to end like great ended.
Better than most. Well, I mean, you know yeah.
It's better than like what happened to like you.
Harsher, right? Yeah. Oh yeah. Yeah. Like the last.
Doctors go completely got it.
You can tell when an,
when an author just like has to wrap things up in five chapters or something,
and you're just like some, some,
some stuff that they've been building up for like a hundred to 200 chapters just
gets wrapped up in 10 chapters. What the? Who is this?
Like the opposite of that with, uh, what's the monger cover hunt article.
He introduces like the dark continent when he can't make one chapter.
And he's like, huh.
Expand the world. Tenfold. I, uh, I tweeted out about it the other day,
but I found out the other day that in the span that it took togarashi to release
chap a volume 32 to 33 assassination classroom started and ended
my God.
No Hunter. Hunter has been on hiatus, not hiatus. Basically.
We had a chapter like once every two weeks.
No, it's definitely a hiatus. We got a check one time.
H X, H is short for hiatus. What counts as that.
Hiatus nowadays is, is it like a Hunter, Hunter hiatus or bezerk?
Muira hiatus. I mean, that's kind of the same thing. It's just like, maybe it's,
there's a very slow release schedule. You know what I mean?
But have you seen some of Hunter Hunter's latest chapters?
Have you seen some of the dark continent chapters? I've I've I've read,
I've seen like some of the later chapters and some of them are just literally
there are pages that it's just all text. There's like one character.
I actually saw it on Twitter, right? Yeah. It's just a full page of text.
And at this point I'm just like too gushy. If you want to write a line novel,
just realize the lighten up.
This man,
this manga is just somehow like writing a book without realizing that I don't
know how.
Kind of releasing volumes on the schedule of like light normal. Exactly.
It's like, why are we pretending that this is a Monga anymore? You know?
And like the drawings. Oh my God. Like, yeah.
Yeah. I mean, even art man. Just do it already. Like what's going on?
What I want to know is like, cause I don't think togarashi uses assistance.
Uh, maybe, probably not.
If not, it's all assumptions. I think you'd think that again, resistance to dry,
right? His wife. Oh, well yeah. His wife is the author of sail ships.
Yeah, we did.
One of the greatest of all time I listened to them.
Was Hunter. If you haven't read or seen it, just do it. It's amazing.
But Cooper had for just.
Guess here's the thing. I haven't read.
Honda Honda at all, but I have all of the volumes up until this point.
Honestly, watch the enemy. The enemy is so good. He's great. Yeah.
It's, it's one of the few Animade that I think is better than the manga really?
And that's because the 2011 version, the 2011 version,
because some of the later, uh, like arcs, especially the co com era and talk,
um, to gosh, his arc is really up and down because of his health complications.
They was going through both like the animate is just consistent throughout.
So then when he doesn't know, I would,
I would recommend him because I'd recommend.
So much about the series, like of like characters and like,
I know so many, so many references,
but I've never actually sat down and riddle water. I think.
I know enough about Naruto to like, to like lie,
lie my way through a conversation and be like, Oh, you have to leave.
I could probably live on way through a full metal Alchemist.
I have done many times. Yeah. She's so sad. Let's be real. Like,
I feel we've all done that. Right?
I like everyone around you is talking about an enemy and you're kind of just
like, ah, yeah. That thing.
Yeah. I was an anime fan who had them watch even galleon people would be like,
dude, it's Epic. Right? I'm like, yeah. It'd be like getting the robot.
No, my dad hates me.
[inaudible] this is crazy.
I admittedly did that a little bit with, um, with, for.
Insecure. Right? I did that for a while with bleach because I didn't,
I dropped it at, uh, the Eisenach. So anything after that,
I had no idea, but people around me kept reading it and they were like, yeah,
you know, the whole like wicked Munos stuff. I was like, yeah.
Yeah. That totally.
One of, one of those anime or manga that you could,
you could feasibly lie your way out of it and make it seem like you've seen it
without having seen it off after you've watched like a further first few walks,
then you kinda just kinda just can just push it your way.
I too also want to see more bang.
One piece. Right? Cause one piece is so long. It's like the Simpsons right.
Where everything that could ever happen has probably happened.
So you could be like, dude,
my favorite episode is where like Homer Simpson becomes a crack addict.
That's probably an episode.
That's right. I mean, you could probably do that with one piece of right now.
So you can just randomly be like, yeah,
I love that episode with loofy and chopper make out.
Yep. I love the part where the pirates find another band of pirates that are bad
initially and then turn and a part of some military. And then they're like,
do let's just be good. Let's help loofy out. Right.
[Inaudible] that probably happened.
That was vague enough that if I keep it vague,
that could be about four different arcs. I know enough.
The base information about one piece. I still aren't ready yet. Again,
I downloaded some episodes, some chapters on my phone.
So you're downloading a lot of chapters now. I see.
I have like 10 volumes downloaded, which is much how far into it.
I don't know because we're approaching what volume? A hundred of one piece.
So we're approaching chapter a thousand, I think all the way,
which is going to be a landmark and yeah,
a thousand chapters that's.
Can you imagine two a thousand every week, a thousand.
Challenges cannot a thousand weeks.
At least minimum because he married the author. I think so.
I think it's kind of [inaudible] actually,
because old age [inaudible].
They're like you can't be married and make one piece like it's pick one.
Well, it's so interesting because like, I feel not like,
because like not a whole lot about odor is even known because he's so
rarely makes any like TV appearances or like interview appearances because it's
too busy, writing a chapter a week. Right.
We'll just do that.
Cause odor out of every author is way more involved in the anime production as
well. Because normally producer, normally a lot of Amie productions,
people were just like, okay, there's the author.
And then the author just gets sidelined and they just continue doing that stuff.
And maybe they'll watch the anime, you know? But you know,
OOD has been involved in a lot of the anime production, which I did.
Where does he find the time to do this? I don't know.
I like as a man is like a time management machine.
Shown in jump author. I don't know how you can have a life.
Like most authors don't have a life outside their magazine. I mean,
most of them have health complications because of how much they work.
Not to mention that.
Like I swear with every new chapter odors art is just evolving.
Like it's getting more,
like some of the recent chapters are so detailed where it's like,
how do you draw this in a week? Yeah, exactly.
Why people like to on one piece character designs because Oh,
it looks cartoonish looks childish, weird. They do look weird.
At least it's like so distinct to the point where you can look at a character
and be like, Oh yeah, that's one piece guy.
Yeah. Yeah. That's true. But you said about Simpsons,
but you don't have a family guy.
And I would argue that that's better than a generic OSS looking character that
could fit into any [inaudible] or any one of.
Oh,
does character designs is way more memorable than here's generic ISA protagonist
number 75 that looks like Kirito just Ruskin's you know what I mean?
Like that's, that's what I think.
I think that's my biggest problem with a lot of light novel adaptations is that
you can tell, lighten up adaptations nowadays by just by just the character,
how they look and just the art styles, right?
Yeah. Because the character designs haven't changed from like 10 years ago.
That's like good looking boy with average propulsions with a spiky hair,
color it in color. There you go.
Even a lot of like the girls as well.
Cause I think when one is pink head character, like, like one of my favorites,
one of my favorite female characters to come out of recent times is my soccer
Jima from Bonnie Gail senpai.
And like, I really liked all.
Of the cars there and all of the characters, but my God,
they have such forgettable character designs. You know what I mean?
Compared to some of, some of the characters times from say,
like mana Guthrie or something like that, which, you know,
it gets compared to compared to lots of, and I see the same charm,
but in terms of the memorability of the character designs,
it's just Bonnie Gil's senpai just looks like the most generic. Well, I mean,
that's why that's.
One of the reasons I just didn't watch it.
That's why they had to put her in a bunny costume. Right.
Differentiate between all the other characters.
I'm just, there's a lot of anime characters just like silhouette.
Or eyes. Right. You can just know. Right.
And like, you know, I would argue again, like that's,
I think one of the strong suits about one piece, right? Is that like,
because the character looks so wacky,
you can immediately tell that's a one-piece character. Yeah. Yeah.
And it's the way I describe odor is it it's some,
it's like you're reading a story from someone who has the imagination of a
ten-year-old,
but the writing skills of like George RR Martin or something like that,
you know what I mean? It's it's,
it's so weird because you see a character like this cross-dressing ballerina,
for example. And you're like, what is this wacky Carter? Yeah. Yeah. Uh,
Mr. Too.
Yeah. Mr. T I miss it too. Oh yeah.
I always get the numbers mixed up clay summer.
Mr. Mr. Green eggs and ham.
Yeah.
You see his character designed for the first time and you're just like this.
I'm never going to give a about this character.
And then he ends up in later ox bringing you to tears sometimes. And just like,
how did this happen? How, how does he make,
how did odor make me care about this person right now that you can see on
screen?
Anyone who hasn't watched one piece is probably looking at this being like what
the cloud, who is this literal cloud. You know what I mean?
That's true.
Your weekly Jack off to, to one piece, a segment of the POG. Yeah.
Yeah. As we're going to do every week now,
are we going to do every week until you, until you start reading it,
I read it will become a one piece podcast.
No, it won't. But it might become more of a Mongo podcast.
I mean, my, my I'll spend like 20 hours reading a Maga. My review will be like,
yes. All right.
So wait, so what would you give out of 10.
Claimable? I'm six, six, six. I see.
I don't want to read anyone else's reviews of Mongo at all. I don't want to.
No. Cause I feel like right now, because I don't head out because I don't.
Touch anything with reviews in terms of market.
I don't know what the popular opinion is.
I don't know if I should go to a thing you think it's good or bad?
I just see something I'm like, I'll read that and make up my own choice.
Kind of like it, that in my own bubble of like,
I don't give a what anyone else thinks.